uh uh for being here and uh so we will
shoot for
30 minutes uh and uh
if there are questions along the way
that takes attack take up some time then
we can go a little bit over but
otherwise that's roughly the
time frame and uh yeah please go ahead
yeah thank you very much thank you for
having me uh this is joint work with
elaine she who just moved to cmu
i think she's technically still in
cornell but uh
i'm gonna say she's insane you know and
rafael pass
and together we try to think about
distributed systems and trying to think
of economic criteria for security rather
than
um consensus criteria for security
so the first kind of obvious part of it
or the motivation of this is that the
payment systems or some sort of
financial ledger is a necessary part of
any kind of
financial modern economy and the way
that you can
think of this in economic terms is that
they provide memory or record keeping
like the
fact that i uh give a hundred dollar
bill to somebody is valuable
because that's kind of records in some
way
that uh somebody gave me some service
and i kind of
owe him i want to give him some benefit
in exchange but
i don't want to give him the benefit now
i want to give it later so hundred
dollar bills allow this person to go and
give it this dollar bill to
exchange to a service by basically
anybody else in the system
and we don't need to remember that i did
him a favor and somebody else needs to
return the favor
we just have this very convenient money
that like
kind of serves as a memory for this uh
for this
all this um favorite changes
and when we think of distributed ledgers
we think of uh
a distributed way of just recording all
those transactions all this memory
um it seems very natural to just like uh
think of uh replacing the
bank that generates a banknote or the
federal reserve
that issues the paper money with some
decentralized version and a lot of
cryptocurrencies basically said that's
like
we we don't uh we don't need the federal
reserve to
secure um our banknotes we can have a
different secure system and
there's of course a lot of work under
security but what we want to
take in this in this uh talk in this
work is to take some economic
perspective
asking not what are the technical
limitations to an attacker but what are
the economic limitations like if you
have
an economically motivated attacker that
can procure
uh they can cure computational power can
we can
bribe agents um will this attacker be
able to
um benefit from attacking such a system
this is a question that a lot of people
already have been asking about
bitcoin and similar systems and we want
to think about
both bitcoin and similar system and see
whether it's visible to have
a decentralized system that can provide
the record
for a modern economy and be secure in an
economic sense
and at a high level um
i'm gonna talk a bunch uh in the talk
uh to argue that nakamoto is not really
economically secure
and this is regardless of the payment to
miners there's a
very common argument especially about
crypto enthusiasts that you need to have
large mining rewards to keep the system
secure
we try to formally uh analyze the system
under various
uh assumptions and it's pretty hard
to justify such a claim
we think that actually the reasons why
bitcoin is not that
was not attacked have to do with other
things that i'll discuss later
um other cryptocurrencies were attacked
um
and like it's kind of a small number of
examples but it's pretty much aligned
with
the way that we think about what
actually details attack here
um and the other question is given that
like the other obvious question is given
that nakamoto doesn't give it
what the security they want is this a
fundamental problem of any distributed
system or can we get
alternative protocols and we'll say
no it's not the fundamental problem of
distributed systems
there may be other limitations to
distributed systems but
the basic uh fundamental requirement
that the
financial system will be secured that
can be achieved by a distributed system
and by and large the
problem of bitcoin is it favors liveness
over safety
in uh taking consensus terms um
uh if you take a system that makes the
opposite trade-off
a lot of stake designs will give some
proof of concept that can do this
you can actually generate a proof secure
distributed uh system uh that
does not really rely on the incentives
of miners to be secured just designed so
you cannot cheat it
um we'll talk i'll talk a bit about in
the end like why
payments of miners can still be useful
for some things but by and large
we think that's uh payment to miners
taking a disproportional
disproportional emphasis in the
discussion relative to the
actual role they they serve
um so just try stop thinking about this
i want to start by
just thinking about an analogy or like
just thinking what is security in a
traditional system
well when we think about the security in
a traditional system we think of
merchants that have to receive some sort
of payments
and the merchants uh let's say i come to
i come to my grocer
i come at the end of the cha uh
i come to the cashier and i want to take
all my
groceries and give the uh
give the supermarket uh the merchants
some funds in exchange
uh and suppose i decide to write a check
now
the merchant will want to look at the
check and
will do everything in this photo to make
sure that the track is actually valid
what does it mean for the track to be
valid the check the
merchant does not care what the merchant
thinks about the payment the merchant
cares what the bank thinks about the
payment
so i'm gonna look at everything that's
like the banks tells me to check
and if i covered everything that the
bank told me to do
and i know now that the bank will
recognize this payment i'm good i don't
really care what happens except for that
um but if i look at the check
and i miss some things and when i take
it to the bank or some other merchant
and
they catch up to something and say oh
you can't use this check it's not valid
then i'm at a loss so
what we want to think about is the
merchant's perspective
like a merchant will receive some uh
some funds via a transaction or a record
on the ledger and they will need to
verify whether others will actually
recognize
uh will actually recognize this uh this
payment and um i'm using
payment i'll use payment or transaction
for the talk to be concrete but it
equally holds if you think of i'm buying
a
house and somebody made a transfer on
the ledger
the question is whether others will
recognize this transfer when i have a
dispute with somebody else in the future
and i go to the courts i go to somebody
else
will that record in the ledger uh in the
property registry
will actually uh convince other people
that the house is mine okay what a cup
that's what i care about
is this a device that allows me to
convince other people
an underlying necessary assumption for
this is that
we all agree on the monetary system on
the ledger
okay so if we have a revolution and
the property registry just got
annihilated of course like there's
nothing
that we can do yeah uh the
picture here is from india's
demonetization at some point
uh about two years ago i think india
made a huge move to say all the bills on
the left
are no longer valid we have new bills
bills on the right
it was no fault of the bills the this
paper money was
completely secure as effective as
technologically you can have it
uh you can have it made but
society decided to switch systems and
decided that the previous
notes are worth worth nothing
likewise i can make a totally secure
system that prints monopoly money that
nobody is willing to give me anything
for
so a necessary underlying condition for
anybody to acknowledge a payment to me
is that payments on this ledger are
deemed valuable
and we're going to maintain this
assumption throughout like whenever i
say
that the payment is recognized it should
be recognized by somebody
who like me agrees on the rules of the
system
so you can think of this as does an
agreement that we use u.s dollars or
agreement that we use bitcoin and a
bitcoin is worth 10 apples
and that's held fixed
now under this assumption
there may still be some problems from
the merchant if there's some fraud
within the system if i can
forge some checks or you can force
i can commit fraud by sending a bitcoin
transaction
showing you a ledger but then when you
come to
cash it in others will say no you saw
the wrong ledger
come so
one thing that's very helpful and
uh not uh uh
not on the slide and kind of discussed
and lisandro
is uh appropriately listening in
is like that there's a lot of things
that you can verify just by looking at
the ledger assuming that we all agree on
the ledger
and that's just by the magic of the
cryptography
a lot of the problems that visa has is
whether i
actually authorize the transaction with
my credit card
because visas rules say like that if
somebody stole my credit card they're
not allowed to make payments
um we're going to assume away all those
problems saying that's like no we have
a cash like system if you hold my funds
if you hold the key to my bitcoin and
you any photographic sign that
the only question is whether this uh
this record will go on the ledger
so as a merchant basically what i will
need to do
is i will have to have some terminal or
some service or some kind of uh
some kind of verification process well
i look at the data i communicate with
other nodes
and what i try to to verify is
essentially whether this transaction
will actually go into the ledger that
will be the consensus ledger that
others will recognize this is the same
uh
the same uh the same transaction as
being included the ledger as
same as everybody else and
we say that the system provides x
dollars of security economic security to
the system
if the merchant has some process that
allows
the merchant to verify that the
transaction is valid and acknowledged by
others um
unless the merchant pays more than x
so as long as the merchant pays less
than some amount of money
i know that the transaction must be
acknowledged by anybody else
who agrees with me on the rules of the
system
i have a question what do you mean by
pays at most that much does it mean that
the attacker is investing resources in
the attack that
uh caused him to expend this amount of
money or that maybe
i don't know he's he had some money
stashed somewhere that gets
uh confiscated of this amount or like
or any of the above um so
basically any of the above i want to say
the
i i will need to describe the mode of
the world of what the attacker can do
with money
uh but given a model of the world i
would not think of a fixed computational
set of fixed computational power with
they say here's how much it cost to buy
an asic on amazon
given this environment an attacker can't
spend money
buying a six for amazon he can spend
money bribing people he can
can do a lot of things i'm gonna have to
make some assumptions about
what the what the attacker can do but
then i want to translate everything
to how much will it eventually cost the
attacker because attacker will just make
a economic
cost benefit analysis end of the day and
if it's
benefits in more than x dollars he will
do the attack
now i don't want to make an assumption
on how valuable the attack is
uh the how much benefit does that
attacker get from the attack
i don't necessarily know that but it's
much easier to say how much would it
cost to make that attack
so that's what i'm focusing on don't
give a gratification
yeah yeah um
yeah so as i as i just said that was a
great question i will need to make a
bunch of assumptions about what the
world looks like what can i
do by spending money and
uh the first kind of model that i will
start analyzing is let's try to analyze
nakamoto consensus
like the bitcoin consensus protocol um
longest chain protocol uh well miners
just run computer power so assume that
there's no asics
there's no dedicated uh computable
everybody
goes to amazon or mines and bills
on their computer and pays a rental cost
like
per hash you just need to pay some money
think of it as electricity
um let's say that in expectation you
need to do
d hashes to mine a block so
um in this environment
the merchant knows that when it sees a
transaction
it will be recognized by others if it's
part of the longest chain
each point like uh the longest chain
will be the one in consensus
so when the merchant receives the
payment he knows that when i wanna
cash that in use this credit i will go
to another
merchant if the merchant will see this
in the longest chain it will recognize
it
um and i can make sure that transaction
is valid by just checking its
cryptography
um the question is is this going to
really be part of the longest train or
is it going to be discarded along the
way
and as i mentioned maybe i have a
bitcoin node so i
can see how many confirmations i got
whether there
there was a mine block with uh with the
transaction and some
several blocks on top of it uh i can
wait
till the transaction receives ten
confirmation six confirmation how many
confirmations that they want so it's
buried deep within the chain and they
can even use monitoring services though
some services although they will say
oh is anybody trying to do a pollen
chain are there anchor blocks around
whatever you want to monitor you can try
to monitor
um but under this model it doesn't
help you whatever you do you don't get
security from it
and the reason is actually pretty
inherent
uh to the bitcoin protocol that value
that
kind of uh paradises
liveness over safety in a way okay
so if an attacker wants to attack
uh this this uh this merchant
it will do what's commonly called a
double spending attack
basically it's uh an attack that
violates safety like i
did everything that the protocol uh can
tell me to do to
guarantee that some some transaction
some data was committed but
that does not guarantee that somebody
else would see a contradictory ledger
because the miner will just mine a
different chain
will make the alternate chain the
longest block it will need to fork a
bunch of blocks
and we'll need to pay the
cost of mining those blocks so suppose
the miner needs to
mine k blocks each uh
one of those blocks will call it cost
him d
hashes times c cost per hash
but when the attack is successful
the bitcoin protocol will say oh the
longest chain is the consensus chain
essentially saying i did not know of
this other chain until now
this is a situation that could arise if
the network was partitioned
if the network was partitioned we just
say well we go with the longest chain
and just merge
the two partitions this way and now the
attacker is basically regarded as the
honest miner
and once we move to his consensus chain
he receives all the block rewards
from this honest chain because honest
miners
break even okay
honest miners are not doing this out of
the
uh though doing this for profit they
should certainly not be losing money
um the attacker is basically regarded
after the attack is successful as an
honest minor so he's not losing money
either
and the attack is costly for the
attacker and if miners are making a
profit he will make profit as well
um and you may say well this is only if
that tax succeeds
well you can guarantee that the attack
succeeds because you
you just need to print all those uh
all those blocks quickly enough and
under this rental model there's no
limitation on how many blocks you can
get
the period of time so you just print a
lot of blocks to overtake the chain very
quickly and you can
i'll get a probability of uh
success for this attack that's
arbitrarily close to one okay
um yeah
and kind of importantly there's nothing
that
like the merchant can do to prevent this
because even if the merchant
waits for a very long time uh observes
anything that they could observe the
attacker will just wait and start the
attack later
and the cost is
zero regardless of how deep you need to
fork the chain
and i should say that a bunch of people
made this argument before
there's a bunch of papers out there that
kind of say well this
this looks very cheap basically for the
same
arguments that i said but there's a
counter to this saying that well you
assume that
mining miming equipment can be rented
like that's like this is unrealistic
under the current scenario indeed
if we could just pay uh and buy hashes
like bitcoin would not be secure but if
people are locked into the
uh if people are locked into the
mining equipment then it gives a mistake
in the system
and that gives you security and
luckily we have asics now if you want to
mine with bitcoin you can't just
rent equipment you need to buy equipment
you need to put in a fixed sum of money
have an asic in your home and now you
have a stock of capital that's like
locked into the bitcoin system and
cannot be used anything else
um so we take an extreme version
of this kind of system so suppose
mining miners have some specialized
scales equipment
like they have a6 only miners have a6
nobody else has a6 the attacker cannot
buy an asic
there's just a fixed amount of asics out
there you cannot buy them they'll do
just that
but we're gonna assume that those miners
are
for profit entities and they will just
maximize whatever is best for them
now um you may you may say well they're
altruistic they'll save
okay that's that's fine but then you're
relying on the
altruism i wanna have a model well i
don't
have to assume that they'll do the right
thing i wanna see whether economic
incentives make them do the right thing
um and what that tackle will be able to
do is to
try to bribe them like the attacker
cannot
uh procure the a6 directly
but it can pay uh bribes
or just contracts to the miners to tell
them well
i'm gonna pay you a different amount of
money if you attack
if you generate this chain versus this
chain
now the miners do not want the system to
be attacked for various reasons
like you can think of those miners may
have
blocks already in the current chain if
you fold the chain they will lose all
the rewards they have
maybe an attack will cause a devaluation
of the chain
or like various other reasons why you
think that the uh
invested in not having attacks on
bitcoin
i'm gonna have uh all of those
lumped into one letter called ca this is
all the losses that an attacker will
incur
if an attack happens
and what the attacker will do in this
model is just coming to pay
some altilta rewards reward per block
that's
outfielder for each block that miners
will produce for the attack chain
and this can be done fully committedly
by a smart contract so somewhat
ironically
like the reason i can attack those very
easily now is because
of those cryptocurrencies and i'll be
very easy to commit to attacks
um i can just lock in some fancy feeling
and say
every time that somebody produces a hash
on this attack chain
i will collect the reward just put my
address to collect the reward from the
chain but you can collect your money
immediately uh once you present this
attack block
um so now let's look at what this
game uh what is the game that's induced
for the miners okay so
let's start from the table above so
those two
scenarios either the attack is
successful or the attack fails
and the miners can either decide to
attack
um build the attack chain
build the honest chain build a normal
chain
or just shut down and be offline
if you build the honest chain
then you encounter cost of mining cm
because you're on
and you're going to incur this cost
whenever you're honest or you attack
i should say all the payoffs here are
per block
so that was my question so why is it why
is it
like uh per block i mean doesn't
i thought that uh
the money that uh
miners have already in the system stored
so far for example like all their past
uh you know let's say earnings
that's not really like a per block thing
right yeah so the ca should not be per
block
but think of a miner that has one block
i'm thinking of
a decision to make one block
and i'm just thinking pill this one
block
huh um oh
think of this like the normalization
doesn't really matter here that much but
like the
point is close when you think of a minor
that has one block to mine and he thinks
of either mining it on the track chain
or the honest chain
yeah yeah
um so if i mine it on the honest chain
think of that hi this is sorry um can
you
can you be a little bit explicit on like
eric
polish has a similar analysis right
about attacks rational attacks
depending on fixed costs to to buy
equipment and so on
do i recall this right um
do you do buy do you know the paper or
yeah yeah of course yeah
yeah yeah can you can you say a little
bit about the differences like
how where do you deviate um so it
depends on the
there are some versions of the those uh
people by eric and the paper by polo oil
that basically agree with us on the
rental model
and they also talk about a couple of
things that's like will be later like
they
um they let me
uh i'll talk about the paper a bit more
in in a couple of slides when they
consider the valuation of the currency
um but i think that's like they uh
both uh don't formally analyze the case
with asics with fixed movement but they
kind of argue that it's going to make
the system more secure
and i'm trying to kind of make the
argument that this
is kind of hard to justify from a pure
economic modeling perspective okay
yeah um
okay so here is like i'm
going to get to the payoff matrix okay
um
so if an honest my if a miner decides to
mine on the honest chain
then he will collect the reward if the
attack
uh fails but if the attack succeeds like
you won't collect anything because like
this block will just get [ __ ] away and
won't get the money
uh if he minds a block on that action he
doesn't care whether attack
success succeeds or fails because he is
gonna get paid by the attacker
regardless of whether the attack
succeeds or fails so that's why i have
this outfielder
here in both sides but then on the right
and not on the left
um i'm going to have a cost of mining
whenever i'm not offline and
i'm gonna incur the cost of the attack
whenever the attack is successful
um regardless of whether i participate
in the attack or not
because the important thing here is that
with the attack being successful is a
punishment in a sense to the miners
but it's a collective punishment if the
currency devaluates or a6 becomes
less valuable or whatever happens of
this sort
it's a punishment that will uh equally
punish the
miners that participated in the attack
as well as the miners that did not
participate in the attack
so by my choice of attacking or being
honest will not
affect the cost
of the attack to me unless i'm pivotal
unless i can actually change the the
probability that the attack will
succeed or fail
so now consider like a situation which
is the ideal decentralized situation
there's a lot of small miners out there
each miners makes a small
uh percent of the total mining pool that
take them takes up this contract
and now i need to decide should i take
it up or not
well i should think that i'm not going
to be pivotal to the success of the
attack
huh like the if there was 60 percent of
miners
that participate in attack and i'm less
than one percent of course i'm not going
to change the success of the attack
same goes if those 40 percent and the
attack will surely fail again i'm not
going to be pivotal to the success of
the attack
so i should be just looking at each one
of those columns and
compare if the attack fails what is
better for me if they're tech successful
what is better for me
if uh if the
attacker is just willing to pay a reward
that it's least as big as the
reward that miners collect anyway it's
going to be a dominant strategy for
non-pivotal
uh miner to participate in the attack
so that gives us back the result that
even in this model well
asics are fixed cars that are
non-transferable that are hardwired
the attacker can still produce an attack
that's
essentially free to the attacker by just
offering
those um offering those bribery
contracts
um yeah and i think that's well
that's one of the kind of distinctions
from other people's like
buddhist and oil mainly but like there's
a few other papers out there too
um there's a couple of other
considerations
that's like uh that i kind of ignored
and you may argue maybe those are uh
maybe those are important i want to
argue that
uh they're not really gonna be
justifications for why the attack is
costly
so one is that there's a cost of capital
the
attack is not exactly the same as the
owner's miner an honest miner is
paid whatever the miner block the
attacker needs to mine all the blocks up
front and only then collect the payment
so maybe the delay the delay in
collecting the awards is going to be
costly
uh for the attacker and i think this is
like that can make the attack somewhat
expensive like you can say well you pay
the
interest rate over like what you need to
uh pay for the attack but even if you
think like
i need to pay interest over two million
dollars for two days
and for sure i'm gonna make the money
back so it's a very low risk
interest it's very low bank for the back
and very low numbers
if you plug in some reasonable numbers
for mining and
and uh interest rates for pretty short
periods that he can
run the delay either attack on
the other thing that's uh actually eric
bush makes this uh
argument really nicely in his paper what
about the currency collapse
the attacker collects a bunch of block
rewards
um but maybe once the attack comes out
the currency will collapse
and then i collect the rewards in normal
times they will be what two million
dollars but the currency collapse by 50
so i collect only a million dollars from
them and i lost a million dollars for
the attack the attack
does become costly um
eric i think answered very nicely to
this to say
well if this is possible then there's
another form of the attack that's
that's very lucrative which is to short
the currency
right if the attacker loses money uh
when they have uh
when they kill the attack because the
currency collapse it means that they can
make the currency collapse
if you can make the currency collapse
you can benefit from this in other ways
so you can't hold the stick
both ways um if you can make the
currency collapse that's another
vulnerability with the system that's
again not very desirable and
two other things to say to add on top of
that
is one there's an assumption that the
market actually learns that the attack
happened
so there's something pretty inefficient
about this response we all know that an
attack happened
and what did we decide to do about it we
just decided that the currency should
collapse
doesn't seem like the optimal response
if we all know that somebody
stole money yeah to just do this
collective punishment
the second is that a bunch of attacks
did happen and they can't see
the cryptocurrencies that were attacked
did not collapse
so i know it seems like um
to me it sounds like an unconvincing uh
reason why we should think that the
commodore is secure
um so bitcoin was not attacked
so why bitcoin was not attacked given
that i'm basically saying
it's essentially free to attack it well
one thing that makes an attack harder is
if you have large miners if a miner is
pivotal
the argument that they just said before
does not carry through okay
if you're pivotal you decide whether
attack happens or not
then you will need to be paid the cost
of the attack because
you basically make the trade-off do i
may want the attack to happen or not
uh problem with this is this is not
really the centralized
the extreme version of this is you have
one large minus and
we can just call it a bank at this point
the second thing that may be unrealistic
is that i said there's like some driving
contract um but
maybe not all miners will respond to
this maybe they're fixed maybe they're
not listening maybe they'll just like
maybe for whatever reason they just like
being honest and don't
care about anything else well you know
those are maybe realistic considerations
but
i think that's a a pretty problematic
argument for like uh the security of the
system
and you can think of uh executing this
attack by just
basically making the mindful and
recruiting people
um another element
that's very likely that tells people
from executing a text now
is that in order to attack and benefit
you need to have a relationship with a
merchant typically the
prime target for this will be
an exchange you get some money into the
exchange you cash it out and then
you try to cash out twice but if you
have a relationship with attack you
basically stole money from somebody
that should know you um exchanges have
know your customer
laws so in some circumstances
it seems with elaine we try to
kind of dig up and talk to people that's
investigated one of those
double spending attacks and it seems
like they know the
attacker and kind of like that's got
closed under the table
because um you know at the end of the
day
doing a double spending attack is an
illegal activity
and if you know the person the law will
protect you uh
but again this is not a very satisfying
um
uh answer to why should we think the
system of security this is not
really uh decentralized secure system
um last uh
argument that i think is again kind of
uh
who goes back to the collect relapse of
the currency that we may think that this
currency is secured just because like we
all would know
if an attack happened so the fact that
people
say like if that attack would happen the
currency will collapse is because we
know that an attack happened because
some chain came out of nowhere and we
feel that all the time stamps are wrong
so
in other cases where there was an attack
there wasn't any confusion
whether an attack happens that's that's
clear that an attack happened that we
all know about this
uh and instead of just letting the
currency collapse
we can just organize as a community and
say well we can just do a hard fork
and totally negate all the effects of
the attack
uh so this will be either easier under
ethereum
if it was properly spelled here um
if you have a community that can kind of
coordinate and talk to each other
like that i think it will be a pretty
bad idea to attack ethereum
probably they will just go to twitter
say oh we were attacked let's just like
under this mess
um if you think of ethereum classic well
code is low we're not gonna do any
intervention we don't do exactly what
the code
does that means that we're basically not
going to respond it this way and
it would be much easier to attack and
ethereum classic was attacked
um okay so
given that like we have this hard fork
that kind of
answers thing and like the lack of
security overall
in bitcoin without uh without reliance
on some things that are at the end of
the external to the protocol
uh we want to go back to the drawing
board and say like can we have
other cryptocurrencies other distributed
protocols that will be secure
and i'm just going back to uh
traditional payment system and ask how
do they maintain security
and basically all the security features
on the check that i showed you in the
beginning
uh basically miss normals okay like
they're not what provides a security
today
what provides the security is that when
the merchant gets the transaction from
you they call the bank
and they call the bank and say do you
approve this transaction if the bank
says yes that's it
like the merchant is safe yeah and the
bank
uh has to do a bunch of things to make
sure that they can verify by
talking over the phone um but that's it
okay so
what do i put on the screen is like if
you go to
squirrel or a lot of the credit
processing apps it will tell you well
if you're offline you can process
process payments
but it's up to you like you're basically
not secure at all we don't give you
security unless you're actually
able to communicate with us so
can we do the same thing in a
distributed protocol
and the answer is basically yes right so
we just want to have a distributed
protocol
that will kind of bake in the hard fork
into the protocol
or like when i get a transaction i would
like to have
my node my terminal communicate with all
the other nodes and say
do you agree will you accept this
payment and just achieve consensus
among all the nodes once i achieve
consensus i know that like everybody
else will
accept the transaction and
one kind of proof of concept one way of
doing this is checkpointing
so uh bitcoin cash implements some
version of checkpointing there's an
aguilas paper and some other papers out
there that talk about
implementing versions of checkpointing
and like there's some details that i'm
not going to go into
especially given that i have like two
minutes left um
but basically what like those protocols
give you is the opposite trade-off of
what bitcoin does
and bitcoin says i'm gonna give you
liveness under any circumstances
which is hugely problematic because like
that's very easily exploitable by an
attacker
um what's like a checkpointed algorithm
or many of the proof-of-stake algorithm
can do
it's just free for safety saying like
under any circumstances
any transactions is confirmed it's not
going to be contradicted by anybody else
in the system
and you can do this in a fully
decentralized way you don't need to rely
on any central checkpointing mechanism
you just say
when i see something that's old enough
i'm gonna checkpoint it and ignore
anything that contradicts it
um it does require the merchant to be
online
so like the main requirement of this is
like that you will need to call the bank
you will need to call the network uh
and confirmation time may be long like
if you think of
there's a perfect variation to bitcoin
um i will need to wait maybe two hours
before a transaction is confirmed
but once it's confirmed i know that
everybody else will acknowledge that
the transaction went through and this
argument does not depend on the payment
to miners i can have
minimal payments to miners just to keep
the electricity going
and i can still be sure that everybody
else will acknowledge just because they
know that
the consensus protocol guarantees that
to me
um so like i said like uh
this is a trade-off of liveness uh live
this versus
um and i think that's like uh
the right uh trade-off to do like uh
it's
it's by no means like the system that
you would like to have an end but we
think it's a much better starting point
to start with a
system that's at least safe that's a
necessary requirement and build on from
there
um and
if i have two more minutes let me just
take talk uh very quickly about like
do payments to miners still matter um
there will matter if you think of a
merchant that cannot communicate
for much you can communicate you don't
need the payments to mine us to provide
security the system is fully secure if
you don't pay even if you don't pay
merchants minors anything but suppose a
merchant cannot wait for two hours to
confirm the transactions they just see
your credit card and they need to give
you an answer on the spot
given the ledger the record that you
just showed them
um under this scenario proof of work and
proof of stake
give you some security for uh the
offline merchant in different ways
under proof of work you know that the
ledger that you see
was costly to make so an attacker could
not forge it without incurring some cost
and a proof-of-stake that creating this
ledger that you see may be free
but a miner must have been individually
signing
it and locking some funds so it can be
punished so like
i'm i'm implicitly talking about proof
of stake with slashing conditions
so that means that the merch the miner
that produced this ledger
um basically said if i produce a ledger
that
is invalid or false or it violates some
parts of the protocol i agree that
i will be punished by this and to allow
the system to punish me i must lock some
funds
both of those ways would create some
cost for the
attacker who wants to create a
false ledger to deceive the merchant
but they really defend their costs so
under the komodo
you get the money back once the
once the ledger becomes public so the
only thing you pay is the interest
and the checkpoint in nakamoto the
the attacker does not collect the
rewards again
so whatever it cost to make the ledger
that's what is
cost that's the cost of falsifying the
ledger
and the proof of stake with slashing
then
the honest miners um lock some funds
if you give them rewards all that should
cover the interest
because like the honest miners expect to
get the rewards back
so how much am i willing to lock if i
get rewarded
well the over the interest rate is the
amount of money that
will uh make mean difference between
putting this money away in an interest
bank account versus
blocking it here and getting the rewards
so i get one over the interest rate and
think of the interest rate
like for a day or something that that
you like it or a few days
is something on the order one percent so
of course the last one is much more
effective i can get people to lock a lot
of funds
um by paying the award and paying them
the interest rate
the attacker will lose those funds as
opposed to the honest miners who will
get those funds back
um of course it doesn't need to
necessarily spend all the funds
like this is more more secure more of
the stake that
you need to commit to produce the
credible ledger
but it's clearly more effective
and gives you much more cost for the
buck to punish
the dishonest miners rather than make it
costly for everybody
because again the point is to make the
biggest difference between the honest
and dishonest minors
okay um yeah so
that's basically it so let me just wrap
up so we think that
it's very possible uh it's fully
possible to create a decentralized
centralized ledger that's secure the
fact that nakamoto is not secure
is basically uh due to a somewhat
conscious
choice in the protocol design but
i think not like the proper
choice that you want to make if you want
to make an underlying financial system
and of course none of the protocols that
i talk to you about should be regarded
as the final thing there's a lot of
other properties that you want to have
in those systems
but we think this is kind of a starting
point in trying to building up what uh
uh the fundamental property they want is
that the system will be secured
and then we can start talking about what
other properties we want in the system
as well
um thank you very much that's it thank
you jacob
um other questions for jacob
so i do have one i may have missed
something but
so i understand that i think i
understood the point that
okay we don't need large block rewards
to kind of increase the security
we still need miners to get out of get
up
from their couch and go mine for some
reason
is that just primarily based on
transaction fees
or um
like their incentives to even
participate in the protocol i'm not
talking about security i'm just saying
you know is there an incentive
for for somebody to be running these
services uh to maintain the
infrastructure
yeah so of course you still need uh to
pay them
like there's gonna be some electricity
costs but like this is such a negligible
cost currently
of like running bitcoin like the
vast vast majority of the cost of miners
is not on verifying transactions
it's mostly about mining and the mining
serves
little purpose other than providing some
sense of security
so that that goes away you will still
need transaction fees or like uh
minting new coins to pay for the other
cost
but this is small like this is orders of
magnitude is less than what we pay
bitcoin now
okay yeah and so
another question so there is some uh a
security definition
that i guess you're proposing as part of
this work that uh
sort of somebody else could then come
and say look
i you know here i have a protocol
fulfills this definition in terms of
this
game theoretic security and it does
maybe better than i don't know check
pointed
nakamoto in terms of you know some other
you know properties maybe like
transaction throughput or whatever
right yeah is that the sort of
natural next steps or yeah yeah that
would be great that's
that's exactly like what we what we want
to happen
yeah um like we wanna
give people definitions and targets that
will not be
assume some physical constraints on the
system
or assume honest majority i want to ask
is there going to be honest majority and
our definition kind of tries to
incorporate a bit more of the
incentives to get to honest majority and
things like that
are there any caveats in so i'm not sure
i can figure this out on flight are
there any caveats in terms of
these security definitions or let's say
modeling
this one system when it is considered
as not just the only payment system out
there but there are multiple ones
like for example when you do this
heuristic arguments on
on on the security coming from iron a6
there is this trade-off between okay if
the ac click really works just for your
blockchain as opposed to some some asic
that can be used
across multiple blockchains there are
like different security effects that you
get
from the usability of this that hardware
are aware of any sort caveats of this
modeling that
would mean that it's hard to reason
about the overall security of the
of this of such a system within like a
bigger
i guess forest of of systems
uh so we we try to take the most extreme
extreme position where you have an asic
and it's really locks you into this
system
like if you say i have an asic but i can
use it in multiple systems you get
closer to the rent model
yeah okay and of course this there's
a lot of modeling assumption and
different model consumption can lead you
to different results in different
situations something
uh some some properties of the
environment change the economic security
what is visible for the attacker
but what we're trying to do is just to
take the most extreme scenarios if you
can fully rent it's not secure
if you can not rent at all and
everybody's in the system is fully
locked down it's still not secure
so i i don't think that anything in
between will change like this conclusion
it just seems like that
bitcoin uh the security of bitcoin will
be how to justify
thanks are there any more questions
from the rest of the audience
okay so if not uh uh thanks again jacob
for excellent presentation
i think it would be uh good and healthy
to take a five minute break before the
next talk by jing so let's resume in
[Music]
six seven minutes for the last talk of
the workshop
okay thank you